I want to start the show a little bit
differently today instead of talking
about the day's news which we'll get to
and we've got a very interesting
interview coming up for you today I want
to talk about a topic that's getting
more and more attention and that's the
topic of universal basic income or some
version of it we've talked about a
negative income tax the point is an idea
of a non means-tested source of money
for people regardless of employment with
the potential to lift a significant
number of people out of poverty and if
you've been watching the show for any
length of time you know that I'm in
favor of something like this and
sometimes we've answered audience
questions about what I prefer a
universal basic income or a negative
income tax do I have a preference do I
think that all social welfare benefits
should be eliminated along with their
respective bureaucracies and sort of
consolidated into one non means text
tested universal basic income or do we
want to try to target based on income
levels big picture I believe that
something like it is is simply going to
be a necessity right as we rethink
society in the next 10 to 20 years
really are sort of forced to reset the
rethink society due to automation and
technological unemployment and the
continued destruction of jobs
elimination of jobs as a result of
technological advances and changes to
our sort of socio-economic status quo
but in the past I've not just been
completely effusive and a cheerleader of
UVI with no caveats right I've expressed
some concerns in the past about how UVI
would actually be implemented and what
the effect would be or should be or
could be and there's a very interesting
article in TruthDig that I read
yesterday which reminded me that this is
an issue I've been wanting to tackle for
a while and why not today and I don't
want to be cynical right and I and I
haven't wanted to be cynical when
talking about ubi in the past but I've
said that when you see a bunch of ultra
rich CEOs and founders of some of the
biggest corporations especially in tech
and e-commerce companies like Microsoft
Amazon Facebook when you see companies
like that and their CEOs and founders
emphatically and enthusiastically for
universal basic basic income
we should be cautiously optimistic right
hoping that they're in favor of it for
the right reasons
but we also want to kind of verify why
are they so thrilled with the idea of
universal basic income in case in point
Mark Zuckerberg and Elon Musk and
Richard Branson Bill Gates some less
well-known sort of oligarch rich guys
like Stewart Butterfield they've all
expressed that they like the idea of
universal basic income so okay that's
great but we need to really put a
critical eye on why they are so in favor
of it and also how universal basic
income could be sort of appropriated for
the good of what our kind of modern-day
oligarchs right the ultra-rich founders
of these major corporations and if you
think about one way to think about this
would be to say alright well if we put
in universal basic income what wouldn't
change like what would stay the same if
we put in ubi and that can start to sort
of give us an idea about why it might be
appealing to some of the biggest
corporations on the planet if you put in
ubi business and market regulation
doesn't change it remains the same
living wage requirements for people who
are working don't change simply because
you put in universal basic income labor
conditions for people working in not
great conditions right whether it's
sweatshops or whatever the case may be
labor conditions aren't automatically
upgraded because everybody gets eight
grand a year or eleven grand a year or
whatever the proposal might say in
universal basic income college is no
more affordable just because you give
people universal basic income other than
sort of by the obvious nature of them
having a little bit more money but the
problem of the explosive cost of a
college education
that doesn't change merely because you
have universal basic income it's simply
not part of it and in
fact there are many companies that say
they want universal basic income that
are the same companies that are creating
a need for it
outsourcing automation pillaging of
natural resources gigantic carbon
footprints some of these companies
eliminate the need for a lot of these
jobs so they would want people receiving
universal basic income because that's
going to give them back customers that
they would otherwise lose if you start
putting people out of work in the United
States because you outsource production
to China for example some of those
people in the US are no longer going to
be able to afford your product or
service anymore have the government give
them a basic income and now all of a
sudden they get back into the possible
pool of your customers it's perfect and
one of the big tenets or maybe better
said one of the characteristics of
neoliberalism is free market and
corporate power setting up universal
basic income could very easily be used
to number one just create more customers
for the corporations responsible for
eliminating a lot of these jobs and
number two the universal basic income
could be used to push back against
regulation and minimum wage laws and
other pro-worker laws right why do we
need to raise the minimum wage we just
put in place universal basic income
let's keep the minimum wage really low
which benefits these really large
corporations except that by keeping the
minimum wage low the corporation's keep
making their executives richer off of
profits at the expense of paying workers
a living wage and they can hide behind
the creation of ubi and in fact we
already see this right companies like
McDonald's Walmart we've talked about
these companies already in part get away
with paying the terrible wages and
benefits that they pay because lots of
their employees get food stamps and
other social welfare benefits from the
government Social Welfare subsidizes the
terrible wages that some of these very
profitable companies pay in the United
States and ubi could make
that way worse the so-called gig economy
right driving for uber and lyft as an
example major problems they're taking
advantage of contractors rather than
making the drivers employees we need to
be looking at a lot of elements of
what's going on there
throw in a basic income give everybody
nine thousand eleven thousand thirteen
thousand dollars a year well why are we
gonna now get involved in making lyft
and uber change their model yeah
working for them doesn't pay that much
but we passed ubi
don't go after them now everybody's got
their eight thousand bucks as a base
this isn't an argument against universal
basic income to be clear this is a word
of caution
now that ubi is getting more and more
attention it's a word of caution that we
need to think critically about this and
really think about how it would work in
practice now is there a particular
answer or solution that I'm bringing up
no actually I don't know right what I
can tell you is that universal basic
income needs to work in concert with
other really significant structural
changes to our society that quite
frankly I'm pretty skeptical we're gonna
be making anytime soon and I remain
completely convinced about the need for
something like a universal basic income
or a negative income tax or some other
proposal some of some others of which
I've been reviewing and will talk to you
about but I'm Justin as as convinced
that just dropping nine thousand dollars
in everybody's pocket every year or
eleven thousand dollars isn't going to
fix a lot of the structural problems
that we have in our socio-economic
reality and at its core when you give
everybody nine thousand dollars you do
nothing to deal with the problem of
income and wealth inequality which has
economic consequences it has social
consequences it has psychological
consequences that we've talked about
about just these drastic and growing
disparities between rich and poor so
what I would like to hear from you is
specifically what else needs to happen
in concert whether you
reversal basic income to actually make
this something that would be a net
benefit in total aside from just again
dropping nine thousand dollars in
people's laps which i think is a good
thing I think that ubi and these concert
concepts are something that is they're
not only good ideas they're gonna be
necessary ideas in the next ten to
twenty years in the United States but
they're not gonna do anything about so
many of the other problems that we have
and what we need to be a hundred person
eads to be crystal clear as we advocate
for ubi that it cannot be used by the
rich and by big corporations and by
oligarchs to say we don't need to
regulate we don't need living wage we
don't need to do anything else because
we did drop 9000 bucks into everybody's
pocket that's my concern at this point I
do wonder whether or not the universal
basic income would be entirely good for
the rich in corporations though because
the ubi would be redistributed right I
mean those that money would have to come
from somewhere it would likely come from
the rich so maybe they would see their
taxes increase so when people like Mark
Zuckerberg or Elon Musk come out and say
we're in favor of universal basic income
maybe they are just acting in the best
interest of the country and want to pay
it forward yeah I mean most of the
proposals wouldn't require an increase
in taxes because you would just
reshuffle other programs that are out
there and you might even actually save
money it because you would eliminate the
bureaucracies required for a lot of
those programs so welfare state so in
that case it actually it wouldn't
necessarily have that effect but we'll
follow it I'm interested in hearing from
the audience what your thoughts are I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman and the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show if
you've been hearing about Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency and you want to get
involved maybe buy a little but you just
don't know how coin base is for you coin
base is the world's most used way to buy
sell and use Bitcoin aetherium light
coin and Bitcoin cash if you sign up
through david pakman.com slash coin base
and buy or transfer $100 worth of
Bitcoin you'll get a $10 bonus and so
will we
so you'll be supporting the David Pakman
show sign up today at david pakman.com
/ coinbase